he'll on the double-team Botox
stolen by James James nice bounce pass
derrick rose up on under his the blazing
speed of John Wall
love good open look Corner three routers
home
[Applause]
the Cavaliers spacing I took three
seconds after the ball went through the
hoop the other night on the other end
good help there from Zzyzx blue Greg
spinning falls down James picks it up
three on one if they hurry James all the
way the finish here in the first half
James to Crowder Crowder contested three
is good for top right this face of
Crowder nailed it minimum contracts
James drives it hard
finishes and one again just overpowering
well they just spread it out with some
movement Kyle Korver's on the floor
you're not gonna help off there you're
trying not to help off the corner
rebound blocked from behind by James hip
comes Rose pushing it up the floor Rose
drives layup misses Crowder right there
on the follow team fouls on they had too
many James turnaround jumper nice soft
touch and LeBron James now with 30
points relooking James goes back for
inside count and Laura
when a back screen is set for James and
it's set by a point guard that's Tim
Frazier's man you've got to read that if
you're Mahim eating come across marvels
at LeBron James's play making he says
he's seen a for every defense imagine
that he will just pick you apart no
matter what you throw at him and he
knocks down another fall away jumper
James to get layups and rolls to the rim
shot clock at five James backs in turns
toward a baseline tucks it in LeBron
James once again
he's got forty seven eight to shoot
sets for three Hudson and LeBron James
with 52 he milks the whole possession
junior Smith good job flipping the pick
again but their problems are still real
James that low shot Scott and the foul
56 points of counting the play design
LeBron James like he's setting a stagger
screen along the baseline then ducks in
and Derrick Rose a great fine wall time
good play design